boom-boom-boom-boom-boom what's up
everyone welcome to simulation I'm your
host Don sake I'm really excited to be
talking about our thoughts on impulsive
x' first three episodes there is a very
interesting movement that's going on in
our world and that movement is the
vodcast movement vodcasts are
proliferating all across the world right
now especially in the United States
they're becoming more and more popular
we see this here with Logan Paul's new
vodcast called impulsive and furthermore
there are more and more people popping
up in this space that are being told hey
get your own video show hey get your own
podcast hey so there's more and more
push for eyeballs more and more push for
attention across our world and we have
absolutely no idea where that's going
with the attention economy yet it's a
very difficult future to predict but one
thing that we know for sure is that it's
really important to get people's
attention so that your messages your
mimetics can be disseminated through the
universe to the masses to as many people
as possible so absolutely nuts that this
is going on right now and I'm here to
unpack the nuance of impulsive because
actually Logan's had some interesting
guests on that have been discussing some
things that I think are important to
talk about especially network effects
and network theory and the way that
those things are playing out in our
world so as you can see here
Logan sits down with his roommates his
roommates are Big Mike and Spencer
Taylor and Spencers on the right Big
Mike's on the left and their first
episode was with the sex therapist
called her name's dr. Shannon Shabbos
and so they went into depth on on sexual
health on sexual energy on doing things
like using tinder or Bumble or these
other new-age platforms to connect with
other people and so I want to start
unpacking the nuance of this one and
then we'll get further into the network
effects with Joe Josiah the second guest
on the podcast and then summer-rae the
third guest
the podcast definitely enjoy this this
beautiful waterfall behind me the serene
sort of nature I love this image I've
been using it now it's so good
alright so let's jump into this by
talking about the importance of sex and
sexual health and understanding kind of
sexual mmm the sexual the variables that
go into sex between people and this is
becoming more and more important to
understand because so many people are
using tinder using bumble they're trying
to push for sexual play with each other
in new ways that have yet to be explored
by civilization these are new
technologies enabling us to connect with
people in this sense and so a lot of the
things that were you know that were
discussed I thought were really
important and I don't and I think it's
really important to not necessarily poke
fun at some of these things because
getting when you're having lots of sex
getting tested frequently is extremely
important and making sure that you're in
good sexual health is something that
you're able to then carry with you in
your day to day life as in you can know
that you are in your peak state and your
organ systems and your blood in your
body is not being affected negatively by
sexually transmitted infections and that
and that kind of stuff so this is this
is really important no because for men
it's really hard to test for HPV but
it's a one of the largest contributors
to cervical cancer for women so again
this is extremely important to to unpack
about each other about ourselves and
each other but also to openly and freely
be willing to have consensual loving
caring and beautiful sex with each other
because as you know that's how we
procreate and that's how we continue
civilization forward we wouldn't be able
to go anywhere without sex we would be
stuck at our current generation so keep
having those babies alright I thought
the next point that I want to bring up
here is about DMS so this is becoming
more and more important this whole
influencer network this whole Los
Angeles thing that's blowing up the
whole nodal network that's starting to
blow up around that area especially I'm
you know
our studio here simulation is based in
San Francisco and in San Francisco we
have a high density of really strong
nodal networks of people like scientists
or entrepreneurs or artists or educators
in some sort of tech a lot of its tech
based and that's amazing you know it's
so convey is amazing in that sense a
global leader in that sense but Los
Angeles is a global leader in our art
entertainment acting music and whatnot
so movie so what so what you see is you
see this new phenomenon of of of
Instagram influencers that are starting
to blow up there is like people with 20
million followers on Instagram down in
Los Angeles that are now starting to
connect with each other and are starting
to very do very strange things like get
into each other's photos so each other's
audiences can start getting to know the
other person so you can kind of take
maybe a couple hundred thousand of your
followers and give them to someone and
someone else can get a couple hundred
thousand if you are followers by taking
a photo with someone it is some crazy
network dynamics that are going on and
it's really important to unpack these
things otherwise we will forever be in
our ignorant as other people are going
and exploring these things meanwhile
we're not learning about them but we
have to be taught about these things we
have to have these important sort of
processes disseminated to us so we
better understand what's going on so
this was really interesting they all got
into a conversation about about sliding
into DMS and I thought that was kind of
funny and what they and what I think
they mean by you know sliding into DMS
is that there's been a lot of push on
Instagram for people that kind of like
each other or want to hang out with each
other sexually that they'll just DM each
other direct message each other and
that's a very funny way and I'll get to
this with summer because you know summer
was very not interested in receiving DMS
from men because she pretty much knew
that the men just wanted to have sex
with her whereas you know yes logan and
you know big mike here we're saying like
yo keep sending the DMS over keep
sending them over cuz they're finding it
interesting to parse through these
and to find women that they find
attractive to go out on dates with them
to have sex with them that kind of stuff
and I think that's an interesting way
for people to hook up and network with
each other but it can also be a little
bit as you'll see in the episode of
summer it can be a huge attention suck
and when it's a big attention vortex it
takes you away from doing things like
building your creative endeavoring into
into our world so Shannon Chavez was
talking about very interesting things
about how when you use things like
dating apps that the amount of of
emotional intelligence that you gain
from doing something like that is
limited as though you actually lose
emotional intelligence in many ways with
the tech era because you're no longer
learning how to have that that although
that eye contact with the other person
and you don't know when I brows are
moving or cheekbones are moving or
smiles or frowns or you know there's so
many facial expressions to pursue and
unpracticed understanding and we don't
get that when we go just from the
internet in terms of our our messaging
so I thought that was really interesting
about how this could potentially be a
decrease in EQ emotional intelligence
and we are losing these body cues we're
losing things like pheromones as well
our ability to smell what another person
smells like in the smells that they give
off with their cues and match with them
based on pheromones so these sort of
emotional intelligence is they spread to
things like business to family to other
intimacy's that we have friends as in
the more that we practice emotional
intelligence the better and better we
get at actually carrying that through
from an intimate relationship to our
business and our family and whatnot so
extremely important to learn that but
you know at the same time there's a lot
of neural diversity that's going on and
what I mean by that is that there's a
lot of Gen Z kids that are not really so
focused on emotional intelligence and
even Millennials they're more focused on
on maybe watching a content on YouTube
that really inspires them and they
want to focus so much other time on
their social Liz ations so I find that
really interesting as well so it's not
about a push but it's more like let's
have a conversation about what works for
each person because different things are
gonna work for different people we've
known that for a long time all right
so except for things like world peace
because world peace is super super
important that everybody agrees on that
and that there is no difference in that
sense it's ridiculous there's so much
nuance to everything and that's been you
can call me Alan nuance sake on let's
just roll with that from now on Alan
nuanced sake Alan nuanced sake on Alan
nuanced sake on all right so all right
so what else um now as we as we continue
unpacking the things that were that were
discussed on that episode there's other
things like when you see these like kind
of like these photos that are being
posted online swiping culture has made
it so that we try and put ourselves in
our absolute sexiest forward our total
sexiest and these are the tannest
hottest the most beautiful most relaxing
most in the most exotic locations photos
ever and that's that's what we put on
our Instagram you've seen some photos
that I've posted on Instagram of myself
going like this right I've done things
like because I I want us to feel more
comfortable posting photos that aren't
so attractive because I think that that
is that's attractive it's eccentric it's
different it's being a maverick which is
very interesting for Logan to think
about yes waving culture has been very
interesting now it's important to not be
facetious a flippant on these issues
showing a serious or respectful attitude
towards sexual health can be very
important especially for a lot of women
that are currently experiencing issues
with the way that that men are treating
them sexually and so in in and for push
for equality of opportunity and equal
and respect in general
so yeah this so so this was this was
kind of interesting there was a there
was a brief conversation about how there
is like a fear of doing something in
front of other people like with a
partner you can have a fear of going to
the bathroom right you can't you might
not be able to pee or poo or you might
not be able to to do certain things in
front of a partner and that's a very
interesting sort of like you know moment
for you to realize like why is that how
is that affecting me and talk talking to
other people about that without there
being shame about it and just being open
and and and totally okay with talking
about it I can't believe Logan said that
he might want to adopt a kid it's kind
of crazy to think about about there
being like a like a mini Logan Paul kind
of like there's a mini Jake Paul right
now which will get into the network
effect in the Joe Josie web so that are
the segments that one's gonna be super
long so we got a we got to keep we got
to keep rolling morning sex is really
important we haven't talked about that
enough yet morning sex people have more
morning sex morning sex will get you
going for the day some people's partners
wake up at different hours like I used
to have a partner where I had to wake up
at like noon and she would wake up at 8
a.m. and so we wouldn't be able to have
sex in the morning and at night she'd be
tired and I'd stayed up stay up later so
that had something to do with our
intimacy levels and I think it's
important to have more sex in the
mornings because that can be a great
jumpstart for the rest of your day and
you can you can do things like have oral
sex with each other
instead of having a makeout with each
other because there's morning breath or
go brush your teeth and get back into
bed as she was saying Shannon was saying
and yeah just you know really activating
your full mind body soul and spirit with
someone else can be very profoundly
interesting that love that you can get
to someone else and you can actually
take irrational behaviors when you're so
in love you can actually become quite
irrational but it's also very
interesting because you can learn a lot
from being SuperDuper in love with
someone like that and so okay just to
wrap up the first the first episode that
there was a
like the fact that attention is so
important in relationships between men
and women it's so difficult for them to
balance like when two really powerful
notes come together like really really
powerful ones they need time to build
what they're building into the world so
it's not just so easy as when two people
aren't building that much they can pass
more time together and give each other
more attention but when they are trying
to build something into the world it
takes them more time to build that into
the world and therefore they can spend
less time with each other so I find that
to be very very very interesting to
embody and spread to other people and
yeah and just having great communication
with partners is super important reading
situations well so we don't have any
sexual misconduct that occur so that we
have optimal sexual consent occurring um
you can go check out our episode with
Aurora Quinn Elmore on on on
enthusiastic consent culture that was a
really good episode where she talked
about that in depth our moving on to Jo
Jo see what Jo Jo see WA is very very
cool and the reason why I say she's very
very cool is because there's this sort
of there's this youthful spirit er she's
fifteen and a half years old and at 15
and a half she's doing insanely
interesting things she has she has her
brand of bows these bows that she's you
know wearing in her head here and that
her friends are also wearing in this
music video called dream which I'll talk
about in a moment
um she sold 40 million of those bows
last year and that was a big deal when
we were talking when I was hearing that
unimposing because for someone to be
able to sell 40 million bows across
targeting all these other retail
locations in one year is a huge deal for
fifteen and a half year old that
probably puts her into the multi
millionaire rankings plus she's on the
collodion and she does these videos and
she's vlogs and all this other kind of
stuff and she has a big following across
her platforms on Instagram she's got
seven and a half million followers and
she is she's just she's just
crushing I'm going to go over those
lyrics in a moment and when she was on
the show they were unpacking kind of her
like business acumen and kind of like
what's going on with her and and she she
was saying some very thought-provoking
things like the one of the things that I
thought was really important that she
was teaching was that Gwen Stefani who
is a really interesting artist and
singer a musician that she said her
advice to Jo Jo see WA was to keep your
clothes on and I thought that was really
profound advice because I don't think
enough especially young girls are
getting that advice well because some
girls want to treat their body like in a
beautiful aesthetic and you're totally
welcome to do so because it's if you
want to do that but at the same time
when young girls are also taught about
how they can and young boys as well how
they can not do that focus on aesthetic
but maybe focus on in knowledge
synthesis and and dissemination that
that they can maybe achieve a different
sort of goal in their life so anyway I
think that was a really interesting
point that she said but she's been
working super hard this girl Jo Jo see
were like 8:00 a.m. to 8:00 p.m. will be
at Nickelodeon then she'll come back do
a vlog and hustle like that's so crazy
she's 15 and a half and she's doing that
and so it's crazy that she's had this
help from her mom her mom was also
helping her go through dance practice
and singing practice and you know and
and doing the choreography for all this
stuff and and she was on a show with her
and everything and these sort of like
you know just insanely hard work ethics
when you work really hard you're going
to get a disproportionate amount of
rewards but you have to keep working
that hard so this is the idea of the
competence hierarchy is that this is not
in many ways like Jo Jo see WA you can't
just be like Oh Jo Jo C was part of the
corrupt patriarchal hierarchy because
she's not she's not at all she's
shattering through every single
oppressive violent structural hindrance
that's in place and she's rocketing
through it in building the future and
she's not letting other people tell her
how to live her
life and slow her down she's just
roaring and building and staying
positive and she's a very bubbly
extroverted personality in that sense
and so I think that's really interesting
to acknowledge is that we're having
these Jen's ears that are just
shattering through limiting beliefs and
building into the world at crazy rates
and I think that's that's super super
interesting okay let's talk about the
song dream so in the song dream you know
she she she says like you know that it's
like if you if you know read this we we
can do it if we see it if you see it you
can be it you believe it you achieve it
you just dr e am so the idea is that if
you can inspire these young people
around the world to write here again
let's read it read it with me here we
can do it if we see it if you see it you
can be it you believe it you achieve it
you just dr e am it's so so interesting
that she wrote that because again
there's been this whole movement of see
it be it see it be it see it be it that
we're hearing around the world and that
it's especially applicable to people in
low SES that need to see people of their
status that have that have made it
through their low SES brackets or people
of color in places like the united
states to see figures in those positions
etc and so i think this is extremely
extremely important and it's so cool
that a fifteen and a half year old is
writing stuff like this so you should go
you know go check out that that that
that video and yeah cuz you know alright
let's let's continue going on and i was
just about to say that the reason why i
can't you know play a video on our
channels like her video or whatever is
because we can get into trouble and
they've youtube's already been delaying
our monetization for the longest time
and i just want to say youtube please
hook us up with our ability to be able
to monetize and grow our channel because
it's getting ridiculous that we've been
waiting for
almost a year to have this channel
monetize so that we can continue growing
our impact it's ridiculous sometimes but
it's understandable cuz it's a massive
conglomerate and it has tons of
enquiries and everything and so that's
why I couldn't play video and show to
you alright um other stuff about about
Jojo that I think's very interesting her
demographics they asked each other about
demos all the time they're like oh
what's your demo well my demo is she
said her demo is 2 to 4 sorry 4 to 12
year olds and I thought that was crazy
so that means four-year-olds are now
starting to get they're starting to get
I like um I phones or iPads and or or
whatever computers and basically they're
able to download the YouTube app and
start watching YouTube and I think
that's kind of nuts because it's like
well okay sure they have access to the
infinite amount of wisdom on the
internet but do they have access to do
they do they focus on getting these like
cognitively driving or emotionally
driving activities that they can be
doing on the internet with the
technology not necessarily true they can
get sucked into like conspicuous
consumption or materialism vortexes on
the Internet
so it's also extremely important to know
but these demographics are crazy cuz the
lifetime value of having someone like
for example I think there was like a
Chipotle post that she posted basically
if Chipotle King can can get her to
market something to her following two to
14 year olds they can start doing
Chipotle product placements into the
souls of these young kids at a very
young age and that creates a longer
lifetime value of the of the kid which
is absolutely crazy that that kind of
stuff is going on in the world I'll be
synthesizing more of this network
effects stuff into some writings as well
soon so demographics are crazy crazy
crazy and I would like to just make a
comparison because I think that this is
kind of apples and oranges but they're
so because they're fruit they can be
compared or because their colors like if
we say that maybe like you know like
let's say that you la mesilla is like
green and Jojo Co is like purple or
something
and so because Elon is green Elance
having a different impact on the world
and Jojo CYS and but Jojo is still
having an impact on the world my point
being that you know Elon is doing
something in sustainability and
long-term progress on earth towards
electrification and towards space
colonization and etc and jojos doing
something more unlike the inspiration of
the two two fourteen year olds about
getting them to dream something and see
it and then become it and achieve that
thing and so there's just this very
interesting difference between
entertainers and scientists in some ways
and I think that that's an important
distinction to make is like you know
there's a bunch of kids in FIRST
Robotics that I volunteer and judge and
emcee and and and do work with and these
kids and FIRST Robotics are not really
the Jojo suos but they're more so the
engineers electrical engineers
mechanical engineers computer scientists
designers programmers CAD people and
they're young these are like six to 18
year olds that are doing this kind of
stuff so these are the future engineers
and designers so it's like why aren't
they getting a voice how do we help them
get a voice too you know why don't they
have viral YouTube channels right so
like what where Society condition to not
to have had a missing link with
something like that and how do we
potentially augment that and make it
better over time so there's more to talk
about here she she's super against
bullying which is very very interesting
that she that she cares a lot about that
and I really I'm really happy that she
does - actually on the last episode we
did on six nine he's also very against
bullying
she was homeschooled all her life which
is kind of nuts that once someone is
homeschooled that they're able to spend
more time focusing on dancing our
engineering building creating because
they don't have to go to school and they
can actually get socialization at their
at their school they can get so sorry
they need socialization at at their
dance practice or at their art practice
etc so social socialization occurs in
places that are not
necessarily school which is very
interesting so you can get socialization
and homeschooling package together and
and that can be extremely powerful
because they can you can really focus in
on your art at a young age like we saw
with Jojo Co what she was actually able
to achieve with that okay more so is
that she's doing the nuts stadium tours
I can't believe it she's like sold out
her tickets in a day I think for three
thousand five thousand see theaters and
she's doing it in stadiums around the
world and that's what we want to do we
want to fill stadiums with curious
intellectuals for full-day
multidisciplinary events and so it's
interesting that she's doing that as
well
and that you know she rocks it she got
there young she's got there fifteen and
a half it's it's crazy Congrats to her
and that let's get there for the curious
intellectuals as well it's it's kind of
nuts that like that that she's
supporting these these kids called Tatum
and Oakley well let me show you who they
are Tatum and Oakley so these kids are
this is this account as two point two
million followers and it's these two
young identical twins and it's managed
by their parents Tatum and Oakley and
what's nuts about this is that it's like
at what age do we do we say that it's
totally okay to make Instagram and
YouTube accounts for our children that
are not yet birthed into the world so
like our children are still just dating
inside our womb and we're going let's
make them an Instagram and a YouTube
account with their name let's make sure
that we can get them that name okay it's
getting a little bit ridiculous and
excessive but it's also understandable
because it's like network effects stuff
but like what if the kid doesn't want to
be photographed their entire life like
you know they're too young to understand
that but I guess it's also beautiful
aesthetically it's kind of crazy that
this stuff is going on and it's such a
nuanced conversation to have it's it's
it's absolutely nuts and I'm glad that
you're able to see this firsthand what's
what's going on with with even identical
twins
I think two years old now crazy hmm
shout out who will teach robots ethics
bump up bump bump um
check this out simulation series calm
you can find our merch on the site
thought-provoking of course hmm all
right back at it so it's kind of crazy
that this stuff is happening and it's
happening a lot in Los Angeles and we
have to just keep an eye on how this is
going on so they're talking about how
this is crazy that 50% of kids want to
grow up and be YouTube stars or
influencers holy [ __ ] that is nuts if
that's a true statistic that young kids
growing up into the world want to be
YouTube stars or influencers in some way
that is both extremely interesting
because they want to they're very
inspired to want to do that and maybe
they're gonna build incredible things
from that I totally see that as part of
this but I also see potentially a lot of
mental health or anxiety issues or
depressive issues or materialism issues
or follower count issues or brand issues
and all this other kind of stuff coming
up as well and I know we'll make it
through it but I'm just having the
foresight to talk about these things
because I do foresee them as an insanely
important things that are gonna be
coming up in the social media and
attention economy that we're currently
facing so it's crazy that people are
naming their fandom nowadays so you know
like this is videos out not teaching
Logan Paula dance I haven't it's
interesting that they that they did that
they're naming their fandom which is
crazy Logan's called the low gang she
calls her as the c18 errs and so it's
crazy that people are naming their
fandoms this stuff's nuts
Jojo most of JoJo's friends are 25 to 35
years old because she's very
intellectually advanced for her age
Wow Jojo said that she skydives three
times a week I think Logan also skydives
quite often and that's very interesting
isn't that interesting that
these influencers that are super bubbly
in extroverted and now going do things
like go and like face their greatest
fears of jumping out of planes by
themselves and pulling parachutes and
floating down the ground I've skydived
before and it's absolutely incredible
but it's interesting how they do that to
challenge themselves and I think that
that's only a the nascent stages that's
only the beginning of where we see
people challenging their fears and
building what they want into the world
and not being scared and just doing it
so there's a there's kind of another
another thought about about this on the
way out is like I wonder how many people
notice what Jojo went through cuz there
are some videos of her online where she
went through a tremendous amount of work
to get to where she's at so I just want
to make that clear that she went through
a tremendous amount of work to get to
where she's at because a lot of people
think that oh it's just magical that all
these things happen so easily but they
don't it's like a lot of hard work to
get to these places and I want to know
if people have mapped the powerful nodes
in Los Angeles because I know the
billionaires in the world just got
mapped I want to know if these powerful
influencer nodes are getting mapped and
what that looks like cuz they all kind
of are a little bit like very
entertaining outgoing and and
risk-taking and stuff like that and
there's not very many introverted ones
like Christine said Delco is kind of
interesting because she's slightly
heavier set and so because of that she's
actually able to get people of
alternative body types in and see that
see it you can be it type thing which is
very interesting and very important and
so having more kids of other skin colors
having more kids of other sexual
interests or body types and all this
different kind of stuff neurodiversity
again like introverted ones would be so
interesting if we introverted kids that
are super intelligent to be behind the
camera and I'm talking about what
they're building and what they're
thinking because a lot of them are
crunching a lot more information nuance
that's not necessarily related to
entertainment or acting and stuff like
that alright moving on to summer-rae the
last episode so summer-rae is you know
let me show you here
summer Rae is you know here's her on the
here's her on the oops my bad
here's her on the show so here's summer
Rae on the show
and here's her you know here's her
Instagram page and her she's very much
so like a like a model on Instagram and
she's also like an influencer on
Instagram and whatnot but she's also
starting to branch out into like
clothing and merch and other kind of
stuff like that and so I think a lot of
what's going on with this and we'll
unpack this but I think a lot of what's
going on is a lot of these nodes are
starting to are starting to mingle like
the connections made whether it's
through a DM or whether it's through a
connection of some other sort and these
two nodes if let's say ten million
followers meetup they take a picture
together it'd be interesting to map how
many of the followers from that from
that node that has ten million that's
maybe a man go and start following the
woman that has ten million and then how
many from the woman that's I mean go and
start following the man and actually
analyzing these statistics and and
observing what's going on when these
nodes meet and if they take Instagram
stories or Instagram pictures feed
pictures and post those and then what
they're actually talking about so like
how many followers are exchanged and
then also what are they talking about
are they trying to promote each other's
emerge promote each other's ideas like
what's going on in that sense and how
can this be used for the absolute
positively best good for the forgetting
society to be the most beautiful
pinnacle of a civilization it can
possibly be so that's a really
interesting feel to keep an eye on and I
think that you know that's part of what
impulsive is all about impulsive is a
lot about bringing on really powerful
people and talking to them about what
they're working on in this like a
network effect an influencer space so
you know um summer mentioned how she's
like worked really hard on her body and
I think that's really important to
remember is that like this is not just
something that is you know just like
with Jojo it's not something that's just
given to you right and the
and the same things true about Shannon
the first guests and about Logan and
about myself and that these things are
not given to you either that that they
that you've worked hard to become who
you are today and that you've got to
keep working hard in order to continue
achieving your goals and so she she may
she had this quote about like okay well
if I've worked so damn hard to achieve
my goals of having beautiful aesthetic
on my body I'm not just gonna keep the
Ferrari in the garage I'm gonna go and
take it out and show the world and
that's great that you have that
mentality because awesome go and
showcase what you've what you've worked
really hard to achieve to the world go
do it but at the same time it works for
certain people and other people need to
hear kind of what Jojo potentially heard
from Gwen Stefani which was you know
keep your clothes on
so I think that's an important
distinction to make because some people
want to work on their body like Greek
and Roman statues of beautiful men women
etc and I think that's that's that's an
important nuanced distinguish meant to
make between those two things it can
also get a little bit crazy because
there are things going on like summer
has to be careful about her about her
boyfriend that she's keeping on the
low-key because there will be men so she
has like an 80/20 she said demographic
again demos are important to imagine the
demographics of these two nodes that are
colliding look we were talking about ten
million each what are the demographics
is one of them eighteen year old men and
the other one is thirty five year old
women or twelve year old women and
twenty-two year old men etc so how are
these nodes actually mingling and
merging and she said that because of her
boyfriend that she has some of the guys
were you know acting up about that that
we're following her and I thought that
was again that was very interesting that
that that that dynamic exists and that
and that is just that that that that
that same thing applies to maybe women
that follow Logan and whatnot so that
that if he when he gets a girlfriend
that maybe he gets less diems and
whatnot and Logan asked her about dm's
like how and I mentioned this earlier
that she no longer responds to the DMS
because she feels like a lot of the DMS
are just coming from men that want to
have sex with her which I thought was
you know that's a very you know just
just real and honest sort of perspective
and mentality to have is that I'm not
gonna not gonna do that and that's not
you know if that's not of interest to
her that's not of interest to her and
you know good on her for acknowledging
that about herself um so you know she's
got 20 million followers is crazy she's
got that many followers so another point
along with the Ferrari point was that
there's also craziness going on in the
world like like everyone should know
about epicanthoplasty it's something
that's being gifted to asian graduates
and what epicanthoplasty is is it's this
it's this insane removing of the I think
it's called the epicanthal up fold but
I'll show it to you right here it's
absolutely not - check this out so yep
right here epicanthoplasty known
medically as med medial or lateral epic
and to plastics i was i sir g that aims
to lengthen the inner parts of the eye
to make the eye bigger inner corner fold
removal so here it is right here's the
inner inner corner fold right there
removed and you get this more open eye
and that's a western that's something
for the for the west right it's a very
western esque thing is to do that so
that you can look more western from the
east and that kind of stuff is
absolutely nuts that that's going on so
what are we actually pushing onto young
people with cosmetic surgeries cuz
summer said she hasn't gotten any
cosmetic surgery but what what does it
mean when you've actually gone so much
cosmetic surgery for the botox is which
is it's crazy that people are getting
you know Botox for like further for
their foreheads and stuff like that it's
just it's just crazy the butts the boobs
the abs the the the bypass gastro bypass
surgeries that that people are doing
these things to look a certain way
aesthetically and that's kind of like
it's kind of nuts that we're doing that
and it's nuts that there are more obese
people or overweight people now in the
world than there are starving people
things like this are just crazy then we
need to talk talk about them more I'm
not using makeup not going to bed with
makeup will keep you younger I
know the nuance of that so much but it's
it's kind of seems to make sense but
it's also crazy to use a makeup remover
pad on your face every single night
three or sixty five times it's like
maybe you just don't wear so much makeup
maybe you know don't hate me for saying
that I know makeup makes me make
sometimes men and women think that they
look beautiful and whatnot but consider
not wearing makeup consider not like
being completely raw you know think
about like hunter-gatherer stuff like be
raw see what that like see how that
makes you feel and and you know on how
how interesting that is so yeah again
demographics in Los Angeles again for
these influencers summer says that this
is kind of funny she says that that some
some famous guys are cheaters and bad
people and that may be that may be true
and I think that may be same thing for
the famous women that are out there and
that that there are also extremely busy
people so I think a lot of women and men
are trying to get each other's attention
and there's a big disconnect because
when you try and get each other's
attention you're also trying to as
powerful notes build into the world I
mentioned that earlier and so that's a
big issue with relationships I think and
this this branding of that Besson he
actually gave her like a dear it anon a
card but you know D means dick and he
says I gave summer Rae the D it's just
so interestingly click-click Beatty and
like what is that doing to society the
whole click Beatty stuff ah
it's all this nuanced unpack there's
still so much more to talk about
demo demographics are very very
interesting I'm Alexis of Ren I want to
just show you like Alexis ran really
quick she has a very interesting account
because she'd she um she has a lot of
followers but she talks about her like
insecure she talks about like her
insecurities and what are other people's
insecurities and so she's actually I
want to know where that photo was again
I will see if I can find it it might be
I don't know might be like might be this
one let me see if I find it quick yeah
one of my insecurities is my is my five
head what are one of your insecurities
so this kind of stuffs really
interesting because if you're asking
your audience about you about
insecurities what you may actually be
doing is you may be doing a couple
things one thing is you may be they may
be saying oh don't worry about that
you're so beautiful okay there's that
but then there's also people are like oh
well she sees that there are so she's
not perfect and that's actually really
great or maybe you are absolutely
perfect in the way that you are in the
world and that's also another nuance
point but there is a good amount of
people that see that and then think okay
cool now I can admit that you know
people know this about me but look at
how hairy I am you know I'm a very very
hairy person like you can totally tell
that we evolved from from chimps because
when you look at my chest and you know
I've gotten used to that now because I
don't like I I don't anything is
ridiculous when people say things like
oh you're so hairy and like I would get
upset or something so again it's about
embodying the things that make us who we
are and so I just thought that was a
very interesting point that I wanted to
share about what it's like to to explore
things like that about our our accounts
and how we talk to our followings and
whatnot I'm just bringing this back up
again cuz it's crazy that this is
happening with children around the world
that these accounts are being made with
kids like Tatum and Oakley it's just
absolutely lutely lutely crazy and then
I want to bring up I want to bring up a
couple questions on the way out these
like these tribal dynamics are really
strange what I mean by like tribal
dynamics is like when you look at like
the low gang here or you know summer
Rae's gang or see what George OC was
gang etc that these gang dynamics these
followership dynamics like we saw with
the local chaos I fight it's just kind
of crazy that these dynamics exist and
that it's kind of like what's going on
with naming these groups and how they
participate with each other and yeah and
how these nodes can merge and who goes
to which node and stuff like that
so I want to know what percentage of
millennial /nz parents in the u.s. are
divorced and how many are cordial with
each other because I think the
percentage is over 50 percent of
millennial Jensi parents are divorced
and I wonder what percentage are cordial
maybe half of them 25 percent of those
are actually still cordial with each
other that was ridiculous um there was
this part about the the clout the Klaus
clout game because summer Rae moved out
of the clout house and I just want to
make this point really quickly about the
clout house clout game because they have
this like they're building a really
strong influence or network the multiple
houses tons of influencers living there
something crazy is like if you go look
at face banks I don't really get how he
is selling an assault rifle necklace so
he's actually like selling an assault
rifle necklace and as he's complaining
about the recent shootings that were
happening in Los Angeles so again you
have to see how your first principles
align and maybe people that are like
science communicators poly Mass in some
senses emotional intelligence experts
and census can come and help with these
things to open minded individuals and
they can get them being like well maybe
I should change this line to maybe a
peace sign instead of an assault rifle
or something like that
they even eSports League and a bunch of
other stuff and so she moved out of the
cloud house summer did and moved into
her own house because she was seeing
things this is another crazy thing like
when you're living in a communal space
people like communal spaces because
communal spaces bring you a lot of the
community and that's really interesting
but at the same time when you wake up in
the morning and there's girls that are
wearing heels in the kitchen that you
don't even know because they're staying
it's with some of the guys that night
that that's crazy that you know you're
now sharing something supposed to be a
private intimate kitchen space with
people you don't even know like that can
be at both positive and negative it's
kind of crazy I want to know who the
Logan Paul of China is if they're one
exists or who the Logan Paul of the
Middle East is and what I mean by that
is who's the most eccentric maverick II
person in those areas of the world in
Russia and Europe and Brazil and South
America Latin America etc Africa who are
these super centric people and what are
they building how are they impacting
their cultures in those areas and I want
to know what's going on with
the Jen's II kids in those different
countries across the world how those Gen
Z kids are using Instagram and how their
how what their deal is with network
network effects materialism
entertainment etc YouTube and Twitter
I'm curious as to how those effects are
alright that's it for this recap on
impulsive episodes one through three
thank you everyone for tuning in
greatly greatly appreciate it much love
to you all couple things on the way out
is just really start having more
thought-provoking conversation with
other people in your life about network
theories and network effects and what's
going on in Los Angeles stay ahead of
the curve you heard it here first stay
ahead of the curve and also give us your
thoughts in the comments below we'd love
to hear from you again I'm the host of
simulation on Saucon and much love
everyone thank you so much for tuning in
and we will see you soon
much love much love much love peace